[Música]
webb samba diluído e no to e aí a gente
campeonato vocês me está tudo ótimo
estar aqui em são paulo aqui na casa do
joão
antes de começar um vídeo que não reage
pra você é do dia 14 de junho está
fazendo escândalo e um monte colega meu
lá no teatro da assembléia em teresina
onde é quem ingressa ingresso na radical
modos lado de seu na play rock desceu
também na moral tattoo street do centro
pelo ingresso é muito importante que
você não deixe para comprar no dia
porque um dia acaba muito rápido a
galera chega no sesi por ingressos e
acaba rápido então é bom se garantir
logo seu pai logo a logo segunda feira a
segunda feira de manhã agora parte mais
importante do aviso o primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo é a minha página na
minha página eu tenho um controle de
quantas pessoas de são paulo quanto em
minha página enquanto as pessoas de são
luís cunha página pessoal de natal de
manaus e aracaju continha página eu não
quero levar o standard para outra cidade
e pra onde a gente vai afastar e como é
que a gente seleciona a cidade foi
levantada pelo lógico que a gente leva
para onde tem mais jeito então acontece
você quer que eu levo meu stand up com a
sociedade vai aqui embaixo da primeira
unidade inscrição no vídeo curtir a
página quanto mais gente a sociedade
curtir maior chance de ouvir a sociedade
colecionados e curti minha página que a
primeira versão do vídeo você já fez sua
parte não sei por que você quer que eu
vá com a sociedade pode uma semana se
vive aqui eu já vou começar a traçar a
rota para poder levar para um monte de
cidadão muito aí é nóis tô eu já falei
muito a vocês neste canal dessa dessa
parada da tecnologia ela afastar as
pessoas da tecnologia não deixar a
pessoa se vê ali até antigamente
antigamente você tinha aquela frio na
barriga de lá com essa menina conquistar
e tal chegava cantada mais escroto do
mundo ele sabe da mortal envolver um
papo nada bem mas ainda assim não se
conseguia ficar comigo hoje em dia o
cartão farmácia na busca só chegar nele
ainda tem um lado é tudo por internet
tudo não sei o que é uma coisa que
acontece muito de se perguntar tive é
que você tudo que você precisa você ir
procurar na internet já tem mais nada
conta própria de aplicação ea queimar
nada de correr
a vida tentando tentando tentando até
aprender tudo você quer ver na internet
o que acontece quando você encontra as
coisas pela internet cara tem nem sempre
ela foi escrito por uma pessoa que
realmente tenha experiência já está
rodando um blog noiva aqueles blog que
quanto mais clique na postagem mais e
fica lá em cima a notícia e tal eu vi a
notícia dos filmes que eu gostava que eu
cheguei nessa montagem aqui veja e veja
só sete sinais que mostram se a mulher é
boa na cama quando eu nunca li tanta
merda na minha vida só tem 19 anos
eu não sou cara vivida não sou transição
das galáxias ou pequenas galáxias em
busca das bolsas e do universo não é a
quantidade de bosta que a lei essa merda
vou falar pra vocês um com 17 sinais que
mostram se a mulher boa na cama primeiro
ela tem opiniões próprias do tipo não
sei ou seja que não propõe um programa
ou nem mesmo restaurante não é um bom
sinal segundo fx mulheres assertiva sabe
o que quer levam isso pra cama bons
amantes assumir a responsabilidade pelo
seu prazer mas vamos lá como é que faz
para uma mulher que é bom na cama você
vai fazer o enem e aceitar sua cabeça
ficou em uma tomada militar não sabe
aquelas que estão assim não acho que é a
sabe de nada inocente dessas você vê
aquelas assim ó aqui é bem aqui é é
decidida essa daí é boa pra pegar não
gente não tem nada
veja quantas vezes vou falar isso esse
vídeo cada mulher tem um jeito diferente
pode ser aquela mulher não sei como
chegar na cama
número 21 jeito que ela come é fisher
garante que o ritmo que a mulher ataca
comida é produzido na cama e ela mastiga
vagarosamente ou se ela ataca a melancia
com gosto selvagem bom você já sabe o
que espera vamos lá vai você gosta né
o mel é para roupa ela cantando bom vai
ser taboa envenenem então todas aquelas
e consigo mesmo quando essa [__] minha
frente agora quero ver se vai buscar se
diz grato mano não quer dizer que vou
pegar um pão e da contracultura e também
na rua ela fosse bom bulir
é marina você ataca combina com o foco
voltado você vai faz por mim é muita
porrada já foi isso né que está com fome
afinal número 3 picantes ou 2 também a
escolha no prato revela muito o jeito
que a mulher se comporta em dimensões
ela gosta de comidas foz saborosos
prepare se para um sexo mais animal
ela prefere doces e frutas então espere
muito peso mães vão experimentar um
assunto que não está no assunto acho que
já podemos notar que o cara de escrever
negócio destacando na muda o jeito que
ela come que àquela hora de comer comer
não sinto medo do simube picantes como é
que vou saber o que é bom que eu quero
começo é bom separar supermercado pingo
doce de banana e comprar primeiro você
bota cima da mesa passa escola que agora
ela escolheu o doce posse ontem dormi
muito colhão 2000 assim escolher a
primeira é levantar a cabeça baixa
passar roupa na cara dela de animal
[__] número 4 pode passar se começa a
fluir e isso é um bom sinal
não importa o assunto mas parte
esperamos ter muito no futebol tudo bem
se você acompanha não se entende e o
mesmo a portela e fish também é em
fichas meu deus ela é difícil garante
que quem tem na conversa também tem na
campanha tem um fundo de verdade nessa
alternativa aqui
porém eu conheço a escalada viu o menino
brinca costa tinha primeiro sim antes do
elevador vocês se beijam naqueles
momentos iniciais todas as mãos pelo
corpo contra o dela e veja como se
estivesse comendo pêssegos gene suspiro
nesse simples aquecimento então comemore
você tiver sorte grande quanto a
primeira vez que me vejo como se tivesse
como um testemunho já curtiu o dia no
lar mas arrancar e mastigar um curto
geisy suspiros eles manter cimento então
comemora sede na função de cantão citada
no gmail e mexe muito na dela a melhor
foto do an tes a desinibição verbal
muita liberdade para falar sobre certos
detalhes formas de praticar reserva
ela é velha desinibição sexual ou seja
dificilmente ela vai decepcionar com
tiro na boca humana mulher que ia falar
pra me adaptar melhor o seu tempo e roni
e 49 e dá uma tapa time quando tudo bem
na meca liberdade mais na tabela queria
fazer o que é que ele bakiyev ao de seu
corpo e eu não acho que o que a pessoa
fale acho que a pessoa fala muito bem
sobre esse assunto é quer dizer que ela
é boa tem que fala fala fala mas boninho
isso você vai comprovar no decorrer da
sua vida você tiver 2050 fala [__]
verdade que o negócio com isso falo 17 o
desejo é o que importa
você pode até começar a dormir com você
mas se ela não estiver realmente com
vontade não espero que seja tão bom
tesão é essencial o rabo é lógico que o
desenho é essencial até porque se a
mulher não quiser ter um nome pra isso é
estúpido dizer que sexo sem intenção não
é bom você chegar a pessoa falar assim
como esse a coisa vai ficar bom mas eu
acho que vai ficar melhor ainda se
colocação está porque essas dicas de
internet não são as melhores porque a
mulher é cada uma diferente da outra é
aquela que é calado e é [__] na cama tem
aquela que fala papo não faz [__]
nenhuma até aquelas que jeremy beija
como se estivesse comendo percebo
marchena melancia e não faz podem manter
aquelas que estejam mal e é muito boa na
cama importa não importa as mulheres são
todas diferença pode ser o melhor que
pode ser [__] você pode saber tudo sobre
sexo pode saber tudo no lugar certo em
tocar mas se ela não gostar mas ela é
uma coisa bela gata e nunca nunca nunca
nunca descobrir os segredos e b para o
fórum da mulher então a seguinte você
gostou de civis e naquele gostei aqui
embaixo eu quero que você comente aqui
embaixo qual foi a maior basta que você
já leu na internet qual foi a melhor
coisa a melhor utilidade que você já
encontrou na internet começa aqui
embaixo eu quero ver você está no
facebook daquela curtir a praia você
está no twitter dá aquele rp e não
esquece que curtir a minha página é o
primeiro na descrição do vídeo eu saber
de onde uma refeição para saber de onde
rolou pra onde vou mostrar beleza e é
nós série instagram segue o twitter
serve o tempo segue na pauta segue de pé
[Risadas]